there are three easy and reliable
techniques you can use to literally keep
calm and carry on no matter what
first a breathing exercise I want you to
take a deep belly breath through your
nose for five seconds hold it for a
second then push all the air out through
your nose slowly counting to five by
breathing deeply and slowly you can
change the message your brain's
receiving from danger to all is well
now you're ready for the humming
a 2013 study of choristers showed that
singing humming and mantras all help
keep the heart's rhythm in Step so the
next time you feel your heart racing
sing a song or just hum a note the final
tip is to focus when you're busy is
tempting to multitask doing just one
thing at a time with your fullest
attention keeps your mind in the here
and now and is a great Habit to develop
so next time you feel Panic Rising stop
and remember to breathe hum and focus